Emmanuel Macron maintient sa confiance à
Elisabeth borgne hier le chef de l'État
fait savoir que la première ministre
restait à Matignon puisque tout va si
bien pourquoi changer de cap d'après
l'Élysée je cite l'objectif des 100
jours d'apaisement a été tenu à ce
niveau de déconnexion on reste sans voix
il avait un choix à faire entre parler à
son aile droite ou parler à son élève
gauche il garde cette attelage fait de
briques et le broc avec 11 49,3
l'Assemblée nationale avec des textes
qui passent dans la difficulté dès le
meilleur choix madame la Première
ministre a démontré ses compétences sa
résilience sa loyauté envers le
président de la République donc c'est un
bon choix il n'a rien à proposer il n'a
aucune autre aucun autre cap à fixer et
par conséquent le maintien d'isabeth
borne résonne comme un aveu d'échec je
vous entendais à l'instant commenter ce
remaniement sans grand enthousiasme
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire nous on
n'a pas besoin de saluer une méthode de
gouvernement qui a été le gouvernement
isolé les uber files la commission
d'enquête parlementaire demandée par la
France insoumise a rendu son rapport et
une relation opaque et privilégiée je
cite centré manuel Macron et la société
américaine a été pointée du
doigts au fond Chapa plus une semaine
sans que soit évoqué les relations
troubles entre gouvernement lobby et
intérêts privés vous regardez ailleurs
qu'avez-vous apaisé manuel Macron qui
avait alors passé un accord secret avec
la société Hubert à la majorité
présidentielle de cette commission
d'enquête à quant à elle qualifiée ce
rapport final de complotiste tout jeté
comme vous le faites n'est pas crédible
et Monsieur le Député pendant ces 100
jours qu'avez-vous fait de votre côté
qu'avez-vous fait de vos partenaires qui
défilaient dans les manifestations
interdites qu'avez-vous fait vos
partenaires qui criaient tout le monde
déteste la police qu'avez-vous fait de
vos partenaires qui n'arrivaient pas à
condamner les émeutes urbaines et les
violences monsieur député vous les
concombres votre bilan et le nôtre le
nôtre il fait progresser la France
certains sont sur la sellette ils
pourraient être une dizaine au premier
rang desquels papenia est le ministre de
l'éducation nationale Marlène Schiappa
secrétaire d'État à l'économie sociale
et solidaire ou encore François branle
le ministre de la Santé les choix qui
seront ceux qui vont être annoncés dans
les prochaines heures de casting de
changement de ministre novant rien
changer pour le quotidien de vie des
Françaises et des Français le
gouvernement visage 10 à 15 milliards de
coupe claires dans le budget de l'État
c'est terrible alors que ce soit
Elisabeth borne ou qui que ce soit
d'autre ce qui est dur c'est que l'on va
avoir des politiques d'austérité qui va
faire beaucoup de mal au pouvoir d'achat
des Français Ségolène Royal elle a
tweeté avec une facture regardez c'est à
Paris certains bistrots facturent même
les glaçons hashtag canicule #shaleur
c'est la faute de Jean-Luc Mélenchon la
canicule le réchauffement climatique et
la facturation des glaçons c'est lui un
mur de feu à l'ouest d'Athènes nous à 60
km de la capitale grecque mais ces
incendies de forêt sont ce matin sur
plusieurs fronts ça date de 2020 TF1
avait fait un sujet là-dessus et
l'information elle est fausse on n'a pas
de glaçons payant dans les bistrots
parisiens malgré les ordres d'évacuation
certains habitants de ces stations
balnéaires ne sont pas encore parti
il se battent contre ses feux avec des
moyens parfois dérisoirs mauvaise
nouvelle pour les ménages et pour les
entreprises les factures d'électricité
vont de nouveau augmenter le premier
route plus 10% en cause la sortie
progressive du bouclier tarifaire mise
en place pour lutter contre l'inflation
ce sont les conséquences des mauvais
choix politiques de ce gouvernement les
Français vont payer très cher leur
électricité à cause des choix du
gouvernement à quel Garrido assiste à
Avignon à une pièce de théâtre quelqu'un
en profite pour la photographie et c'est
à partir de cette photo que le lien est
fait entre les chaussures qu'elles
portent et
cette paire de chaussures d'une marque
de luxe que je ne citerai pas sans voile
que le Président de la République au
final n'écoute personne il n'écoute que
lui-même et qu'il va encore une fois
taper dans le porte-monnaie des Français
regardez cette réaction donc de Raquel
garredo c'est un scandale non c'est une
sandale offerte par mes filles
rapportées de voyage pas des Hermès
plutôt nups c'est sandales et moi avons
fait plus pour l'augmentation des
salaires la souveraineté du peuple que
les 5 à 1000 macronistes et le pénis qui
nous haïssent